hi I'm Erin Santos I work at EMC
insurance and I'm going to be talking
about how we use the Wolfram language to
explore different insurer tech
technologies
hi my name's Aaron Santos I'm going to
talk about how we use the Wolfram
language to explore different insurer
Tech's so so again I'm Santos I do
insurance here this is the EMC insurance
building in Des Moines EMC is a property
and casualty insurance company they do
they have branch offices mostly centered
throughout the Midwest but really
covering pretty much all 50 states and
it's just a little bit of background on
me so I originally started off as a as a
physicist spent the first however many
years of my career in academia jumping
around from different small liberal arts
colleges finally getting a tenure-track
position in in Iowa and at Simpson
College had an opportunity to
collaborate with some folks from EMC
insurance and they they said hey why
don't you come aboard full-time and you
know if you had asked me when I was in
high school I was thinking I got a
chance to go to an insurance company and
I thought this is the most boring people
I've ever been around
and I want to do insurance and they were
gonna do insurance insurance has changed
quite a bit it is in the the thing I
like to tell people is I learned more in
my first six weeks working at an
insurance company than I did in my
previous six years in in academia and
the reason is that insurance is very
different than it used to be so this is
not your grandfather's insurance company
these are some of the technologies that
we've gotten to explore just in my my
couple of years there so if you look at
the top left that's Lisa Simonetta she's
our senior vice president of claims and
she just sponsored a workshop looking at
virtual reality headsets for use for the
claims to
permit the on the top right we were also
looking at augmented reality we think
there's going to be a lot of
opportunities so things like you have a
some sort of damage to a building with
augmented reality if you can set it up
correctly you can overlay the original
property versus what it looks like now
and get a sense of what the the change
was so that you know and can process
that claim faster insurers are also
doing a lot of work with drones so a lot
of times a hurricane comes through some
states you can't get in necessarily to
see the damage that it's been done it's
very easy to take a drone fly over or an
aerial flyover look at that aerial
footage so we've just started a drone
program at EMC that allows us to look at
roofs and other things that are
difficult to get access from from if
you're just having a person walking on
the ground we're doing a lot of work
with satellite imagery obviously the if
you're ensuring a property the amount of
risk you take and the amount of payout
you're going to have to do to replace
that building if it gets damaged depends
on the material the construction type
the the square footage these are things
we're starting to be able to detect now
over just using using satellite footage
and things like Google Streetview
so I'm going to go through some of the
things that that I've been playing
around with using the Wolfram language
and I'm going to start with just an
analysis of satellite imagery so as I
mentioned business building evaluations
are based on their square footage
typically what happens is we will send a
person out and that person will go there
they're lost control folks usually of an
engineering background they'll go out
they'll physically measure the building
then they'll go and reconstruct that in
CAD to do a valuation of how much that
building is going to cost to replace and
the thing we were interested in is can
we do this a lot faster and make
more scalable so right now we do about
10,000 properties each year we really
want to get that up to the hundred
thousand and we're not gonna have the
personnel to do that but what you can do
fairly quickly and this is something
that Wolfram actually helped us you know
we hired them to help us build the code
right now we can just pull in a
satellite image I'm going to cheat a
little bit here so the original plan was
we were going to use satellite images
and construct a neural net to detect the
outline of those buildings I'm going to
cheat for this talk just because the we
found is that the neural nets are great
if you have tons and tons of training
data we didn't have that but it turns
out there's some cheat codes which is
basically the the Google roadmap view
which gives you the outline of the
building and that gives you a way to
build training data very quickly so I'm
going to use the roadmap from Google and
we just create a bunch of different
functions so you've got construct a mask
from that roadmap we're going to detect
the center building in that mask we're
gonna find the closest point to that to
that building visualize the area compute
the area and then we also have some
functions that can deploy this as an API
so I'm just going to run these quick and
if you want to see what that mask looks
like this will just take a second to run
and you can see we get not only the the
building in this case of school but we
get some of the field houses that are
that are next to it anything that shows
up in the in the map in the mask you can
start to detect the area of so I'm just
gonna have it detect the the center
building I'm gonna ignore those other
two smaller buildings there because it's
the center building we're really
concerned with here we can start to
highlight that on the mask and compute
what the area is so we're doing this
just by pulling images usually satellite
images from Google off and doing some
analytics on them a lot of times what
happens is if you've ever used the
Google Google Maps satellite view it's
not great that's
really picking out the exact building
you want so what we've done is made a
session where you can be a little bit
more interactive so let's say you pull
the building out you know one of the
things I like about the Wolfram language
is it gives you a quick way to make
these interactive apps so you can just
select the building you want you can
take a look at the outline if I decide I
don't want this building I want to move
it down and look at this building over
here I can do that if I want to look at
the area of both images of both
buildings I can do that as well so
that's some work that we were doing with
satellite imagery but we've been doing a
lot of work with image processing in
general and one of the big problems that
we've had is just being able to to label
data very very efficiently so machine
vision requires a large amount of
labeled images and if you're trying to
do classification that's not so hard to
deal with but if you want to actually
segment the image and figure out
something like an area or how big
something is you need to do mass making
which is very time-consuming we were
having interns do it and we were
basically torturing our interns they
were taking hours a day and only getting
through a hundred images or so we've
found a way to reduce that the time - it
takes to make a mask - to under a minute
in some cases just by using manipulate
and the locator tool along with image
forests and components to select
different regions of the image so here's
an image that one of our drones pulled
its images of a roof that has some
ponding issues so I'm just gonna run
this really quick now what I can do just
very efficiently I can select I'll say I
want to look at ponding that's a ponding
spot but this is not ponding and you can
see we can we can start to build masks
very efficiently here so this upper
region over here that's not ponding
that's not ponding this over here in the
extreme end does not pond
so you can very quickly label images
this is something that if we had an
intern doing it they would be sitting
there trying to make polygons around the
ponding region and it just it just takes
forever
this code makes that so that you can get
through you know 30 images an hour and
it it makes it very very efficient so
that's a lot of work that we've been
doing internally we also do work
partnering with outside park outside
groups like startups one of the
companies that we really love is a Des
Moines based company that does some
really innovative stuff and the wearable
space there called make you safe their
basic idea is they have a little armband
that you can put on it's small so it's
not too intrusive if you're working at a
manufacturing plant it has a little
sensor that you can flop in there and it
measures just different different things
that could be associated with potential
losses for for the company or potential
accidents so anytime there's an incident
the device triggers that and incidents
could be something like extreme
temperatures could be humidity so that
you might get some mold the site is too
humid it could be a manual report so
it's the employee senses something's
wrong maybe they trip over something
they can push a button and report an
accident motion which is the one I'm
going to be talking about so detecting
slip trips and Falls which are some of
our biggest hazards noise that's too
loud light detection so if it's too dark
that poses a slipping hazard and that
can lead to lots of losses as well so
the different motion classifications
they have it could be people are running
people are walking slipping and tripping
are the ones we obviously care most
about
and then also no movement so the the way
the device works is it detects the
different incidents it identifies and
provides some feedback that allows the
manufacturer or wherever the site is to
take prescriptive STAC steps to improve
the safety at the site so on our end
that's going to reduce the number of
claims
so we don't we don't build the devices
but we did spend a little bit of time
working with them helping them giving
them feedback on the machine learning
algorithms they were using to detect
slip trips and Falls I'm going to talk
about that for a little bit so the the
wearable device that they have has a
really nice accelerometer that can
measure your X Y Z position so you might
get a graph that looks like this if an
incident is triggered a lot of times it
just happens that the the Weisse happens
to get bumped so you get a big spike in
the acceleration which will cause that
incident to be triggered but sometimes
it's just the person walking if it is a
slip you get a different characteristic
signature and we're using that time
series of data and some classification
procedures some machine learning
technique to classify is the person just
walking or did they actually slip so
make you save had their own proprietary
algorithm that they put together we want
it to compare against that so you can do
we did a click a quick just visual of
what sort of data they were getting and
then we tried to figure out what was
actually happening in their data doing a
little bit more of a deep dive so if you
look at the coordinate system on the
wearable device there's an x-axis that's
pointed forward Y is pointed up and then
Z is pointing into the body and one of
the first things we found in their their
very first run of data that they've
since fixed is we were getting this
screwy data so the acceleration is
measured in units of G and you'd expect
that so G is the acceleration of gravity
which is pointing down that's in the
negative y-direction so you would expect
to get negative one all the time if
you're just standing there now it's
never quite exactly one because people
are you know holding their arms like
this and then the device is not quite
pointed straight up and down or as
they're walking they're moving their
arms back and forth so you would expect
it to be close to negative one but not
always exactly negative one usually a
bit less than negative one and what we
found when we were averaging some of the
curves in this case I think it was for
this slip was that sometimes we were
getting things that were almost always
positive one instead of negative one I
was like
weird so it turned out we could quickly
identify just that the some people were
putting the device and upside down which
you know small small thing easy to
correct but that's the type of things
you want to do you want to learn early
in a pilot but you know talking to
insurance folks there they don't
necessarily have physics background so
it's difficult to visualize what that
coordinate system looks like but again
we can build some very nice fast visuals
where we can say alright this is what
it's going to look like if the person is
wearing it on their left arm you can see
the green axis is what we're measuring
in the y-direction we should get that
for gravity but look if that's upside
down that's going to flip the device
also you got to be careful whether
you're wearing it on the left arm or the
right arm because if you put it on the
right arm all of a sudden your x-axis is
backward so you know simple things that
are easy to correct and easy to classify
and do on the fly so it shouldn't matter
whether you wear it on the left arm or
right arm you can automatically detect
that just based on how the accelerometer
data is appearing and then just flip
your axes accordingly so - to check
their machine learning algorithm we had
like a little bit of a mini internal
contest with our data scientists so we
we try to have like sort of small
calculation competitions it's it's funny
we'll have I made this little paper
crown that's like you get to be the king
of the data scientists a king or queen
of the data scientist and they'll get
really excited about this paper crown
which is like just poorly poorly made
but we did a an internal contest with
this and just to set a - set a bar for
it I just used Wolfram's
internal classify function I think this
is going to come out yes is gonna give
me an issue I don't know why this is
doing this come back try this one more
time
I used Wolfram's internal classify
function just threw it up and we gave
them a day to to analyze the data and
what we found is that most most of the
data scientists we have are using tools
like our
which take a bit more manipulation to
get them to run really well
wool firms classify beat all of our data
scientists so I should I should point
out a couple of things these are not
their actual names I didn't get their
permission so you know I pulled a lot of
names off of funny names offline but the
I think that's one of the real powers of
Mathematica though is that with very
little effort you can get reasonably
good results now to give our data
scientist so a little bit of credit you
know they were busy with other stuff at
this time too so you know they might
have put in just like an hour of work if
they put in more optimization I'm sure
they could have done a better job on
this but it shows the power that what
you can do with Mathematica very very
quickly since it's so very high level
the another area we've been focused on
quite a bit is doing yep yep
back over here yep
oh yeah sorry um I meant to change this
and I apparently did not so the the one
through five are the different
classifications of movement so I forget
which is which but I think one's walking
two is slipping tripping falling Oh the
input is the data that's that's up here
so you're taking the XYZ accelerations
yeah correct exactly yep yeah good
question sorry I didn't I didn't make
that clear earlier so another area we've
been looking at is doing natural
language processing and text extraction
from documents so we have just terabytes
and terabytes of unstructured claims
documents and we have nurses that will
have to put together these medical
timelines and they measure their work
literally in stacks of papers so how
many feet of paper did you get through
in this week obviously if there's
anything we can do to help them out and
automate that process that's something
we want to consider and we've we've
started working on this a bit it's it's
tricky because there's not a lot of
structured data here but one of the
things that is structured is there these
healthcare finance administration forms
that's about 8% of the documents we get
and for any sort of injury case so they
tend to be a bit more common and they're
they're very structured so I have a fake
one here again
having fun with the one of the data
scientists on my team you're not gonna
let me enlarge well I'll just run it and
then you'll you'll see the larger form
one of the data scientists on my team
had fun with the names here so there's
no there's no HIPAA compliance or other
things we're gonna have to worry about
but as you can see it's a very
structured form and if we can just pull
out the information from the different
boxes
we should be able to pre pre-fill our
our databases with the information from
those one of the bits of one of the
problems is that usually we get these
those paper documents that get scanned
in so they don't even necessarily have
OCR on them a lot of times they're
handwritten so we have to find a way to
manage all of that first thing we do is
just detect is the document a hicfa form
which we can just do with the classify
function I'm going to run this now
because this one takes did I forget to
run seem to be missing code in this oh
yes thank you I put it in I switch the
order of it
so there's a lot of functions here I'm
not going to go through any of them
because it's going to take way too long
and I think I'm already running out of
time here but if anybody has questions
we can talk about that later but what we
can do is my data scientist Park you put
a lot of work into standardizing this
form so a lot of times when they get
scanned in they get scanned in at an
angle using the image lines function
that it's fairly easy to correct for
that part of it so this should sticks a
little while to run but we should see a
more standardized version of this and I
think it takes like 10 seconds on our
machine there we go
the so it it binder eise's the the image
uses image lines to get it in the
correct orientation and from that we can
start detecting different fields now if
you look at this form you can see a lot
of times if you look at for example the
the telephone field over here there are
extraneous lines that we have to filter
out and so we put a lot of effort into
just imputing the
take extracting out the the lines that
are there the stray marks and imputing
those values and also I'll walk you
through what that kind of looks like
here so let's say we wanted to extract
the address field the first thing you do
is you just do a crop around that field
so you might get something like this
which you can read fairly easily we
convert that to we call or negate that
and then the text recognizer is usually
pretty good at pulling that information
off you can do a similar thing with the
the names again I didn't pick the names
here but things like that stray mark
will sometimes mess up your your text
recognizer we try to get rid of those
again you color negate and then it can
pull the the text recognizer usually
does a pretty good job of pulling those
names off the here is kind of an extreme
case where a lot of times you'll have
the line going right through the text so
you do that text recognizes generally we
found not going to be able to handle so
you have to do some work eliminating
that line and then we we tend to use the
in paint function which does a pretty
good job of filling in the blanks once
you've gotten rid of it so this is a
icd-9 icd-10 code which tells you the
type of diagnosis and then the beautiful
thing is that once once we've gotten
through extracting this information all
of a sudden we can connect to Wolfram
Alpha and you have that whole knowledge
engine that you can go and say alright
what is this what is this diagnosis code
you know what are the the demographics
of the people who have this disorder
what are the height and weight and then
we can start correlating those other
variables to things like what's going to
be the the time to return to work is
there anything we can do to help improve
that return to work time so I'm gonna
I'm gonna stop here and open up for
questions but I'll just end with a quick
story so just as a summary this is not
your grandfather's insurance
we're doing a lot more things in the
innovation space with drones and yeah I
spent the last two months looking at
augmented and virtual reality which
never would have associated that with an
insurance company Wolfram language is a
great tool I wouldn't work with anything
else for rapidly prototyping new tools
in any sort of innovation space and one
of the things that I learned very
recently is that the the Wolfram
language really spoils you and we were
we were having a meeting with a an IT
consultant and he wanted us to show him
how how we deploy our API and we did you
know cloud deploy and it sent something
up and he was like no you gotta show me
how you deployed the API and we were
like we just did and he could not he was
he's a really smart guy could not wrap
his head around the fact that you could
just deploy an API from within the
system that you were coding in so I
think I at least for me and you guys
maybe have experienced something similar
there's a lot of techniques in the in
the Wolfram language you just learned to
take for granted but then when you see
people who are programming in Python and
are and all they have to do just to get
to the point where they can deploy
models it it could really give you a
sense for for the power of the language
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and stop
there and I guess I will just open up
for for questions
[Applause]